gonna do a reaction video watch one of
the videos that we posted a while ago
and then read the comments and respond
to some of the comments let's see how it
goes when I was younger if you didn't
like your job or if you didn't like your
boss the bad news was you had to stay
there for a year true it's a different
time now back then you had to stay
otherwise it would hurt your resume
that's just a true statement and now
particularly young people there's no
Stigma to quitting and it happens
sometimes too quickly like if your
confrontation avoidant and I've seen it
happen I'm too afraid to ask my boss for
a raise so I just quit or I've been here
for four months I don't like the culture
I quit or I got in trouble at work I
hate my boss I quit and so people are
quitting so much I don't mind if
something's super toxic get the heck out
of true most places are not super toxic
imperfect yes but toxicity is like a
like there's a standard you know so I
think that it's true I mean there's been
a lot said about this and written about
this already
um which is because of a helicopter
parenting that whenever our kids got
uncomfortable we swooped them and solved
the problem so that they wouldn't have
to sit in discomfort as that generation
of people who had helicopter parents are
entering the workforce discomfort is
something that they're uncomfortable
with and the reality is the way we grow
is through discomfort the way we learn
about ourselves through discomfort of
course I'm not telling anybody to stay
in a job that is truly toxic or where
you're being exploited by the company
um but uh but sometimes uncomfortable
things are some of the best leadership
and growth opportunities we have at work
that is true
um if it's repetitive then of course
leave if it's just a little bit of
discomfort or you're going through a
period I I you know I am a great
believer in sticking with it let's keep
going it's a high bar or this doesn't
fit my values or this disagree with my
politics I quit my fear is that if we
Flash Forward five years there's going
to be a disproportionately high number
of people who have eight jobs in five
years and what's going to happen is an
employer is going to look at them be
like
I can't take the risk that you're going
to stick around I'm not hiring you you
sound like an amazing candidate but
you're too high risk for me and because
you've had so many jobs over such a
short period of time you actually
haven't stuck around long enough to
build up a skill set or know what it's
like to manage a storm so this is one of
those predictions that time will tell
you know uh I could be completely wrong
this is what I as somebody who has hired
people and looked at their resumes that
if I saw somebody who bounced around
their job every six months and I'm just
the next on the list
um I am going to ask them about it like
um how come you keep changing jobs but B
it absolutely would make me nervous that
if I hire this person even if they're
fantastic am I going to just lose them
in six months
um I'm going to invest time and energy
and training them and they're going to
fill a a space needed in the company
so just coming from somebody who who
sometimes does hire people
um that would cause me concern
um but you know maybe I'm wrong you've
stuck around in the good times and
bailed in the bad times and so
you have now been in the workforce for
five years but you don't have five years
of work experience you have four months
of work experience and so I don't want
you either because you've never been
through a battle
you know and I see it happening a young
person who's been at a company for eight
months goes to their boss and says I
want to raise I want a significant raise
because I'm doing the same job as those
people those people have been in the
workforce for 10 years I know but I'm
doing the same work as them and I'm
doing good work that's true you are
doing the same work as them and you are
doing good work the difference is I'm
not paying them just because they've
obliquely been in the the workforce for
10 years I'm paying them because you
know how to hoist a Mainsail in calm
Waters and you can Hoist the Mainsail
and calm orders as well as they can
hoist a main sale in com orders the
difference is they also not always the
Mainsail in a storm I don't know if you
can hoist a Mainsail in a storm so I
like the metaphor but
um you know this is one of those things
where
um it's just
The Annoying Thing of somebody who's
been in the workforce for a while
um I had the exact same opinion when I
was young in my career which is I'm
doing the same work I'm doing the same
I'm doing the work better I couldn't
understand why
um I wasn't being paid the same as
people who had been in the workforce
longer than me I I had the exact same
attitude and this is one of those
annoying things for you know people who
are young in their careers to even hear
because it sounds counterintuitive to
their own experience but there is
something to be said for having worked
in the workforce for a while you gain
perspective and point of view and know
how to manage difficult situations just
because of experience not because you're
smarter it's just you should have been
through it before I think you could
apply the same logic to almost
everything you know somebody who's had a
couple of relationships hopefully knows
how to manage them better and somebody
who's you know played a few games of
backgammon
is better at understanding the strategy
of backgammon not because there's
smarter it's because they've had some
experience they've had some practice and
I think having some practice at work uh
is is a true thing again it's annoying
to hear when somebody's young in their
career I get it I had I was the same way
I pay them more
because I know that if if we run into
hard times I know that they know what to
do and I can trust that we can navigate
and I also know that they will teach you
how to hoist a Mainsail in a storm it's
like the same reason I buy insurance I
don't expect my house to burn down but I
pay just in case I'm paying them more
for skill set that I hope they never
have to use that's why they get more
all right let's look at some of the
comments uh just remember speaking from
the perspective of employer
um yes
that's true that's why I share the point
about you know if somebody has lots of
jobs on a resume and they don't stick
around that that would cause me concern
that that is the the perspective of an
employer I'm trying to share the
perspective of what other employers
might think
um why is it always the employees that
must be better but not the employer I do
not believe that at all I believe that
there's a responsibility on both sides
and it's the employer who has to go
first because they have they do have the
perspective and they do have the
experience and they uh
um you know they should exhibit better
leadership qualities
um it's like a relationship nobody says
one party has to be better both at
parties have to be better
um so yeah of course of course
completely agree with that one they have
to be both uh except jobs can actually
have no loyalty to their employees
that's true you can stay for 10 years
um and the new hire will start at a
higher rate there that is true that that
we live in a day and age where companies
do seem to show less loyalty to their
employees we see this the fact that mass
layoffs are a standardized thing now to
balance the books didn't exist uh many
many years ago so
that one's true
um this is hilarious because the minute
the company hits the storm they will
manage by getting rid of the people
agree and I completely am against that
in the defense of young people who are
comfortable with quitting you know it is
companies that set the rules companies
show less loyalty to their employees and
then they're surprised when their
employees show less loyalty to them I
agree it should be it should be an even
street but I'm I'm talking about when a
company does care about their people and
does show loyalty
um that there still seems to be a a
greater comfort with quitting more than
staying but I completely agree with with
that one
um I'm completely against when a company
just you know has a bad year that they
just have layoffs to manage the books I
completely agree with that uh been at
the same place for 10 years stuck it out
hoping for the best because it's so
close to home don't waste your lives
it's not worth it I mean there's truth
in that as well which is it's not all
one thing and all the other thing it's
not like and 10 years is a long time to
stick to the place you know
I mean two or three years or one or two
years to realize if there's opportunity
there I don't think I'd stick somewhere
10 years either uh corporations did this
to our generation they stopped valuing
and taking care of their employees and
in return we stopped being loyal I mean
yes I completely agree and I think so
many of the challenges that employers
are complaining about today were uh were
things that they set in motion over the
past 20 30 years and the fact that we've
we've become so finite-minded and so
short-termest that we care much more
about what the shareholder gets than
what the employee gets I think you're
100 right there to be 911. it's true and
so the question is how do we balance it
and this is the work that I do I'm
trying to get leadership to change I'm
trying to get companies to abandon
everything Jack Welch did to abandon
using mass layoffs to balance the books
that's I agree I agree but I think
there's a push me pull you I think we
kind of just shrug our shoulders and say
you change first change can start from
anywhere
um anyway most places are not super
toxic best piece of fiction I've ever
heard this week
most places aren't super toxic that is a
true statement there might be
dysfunctional leaders that might be
ill-equipped leaders uh there might be
discomfort discomfort
um but super toxic I mean toxicity is
like when you work in a super toxic
place you have somebody yelling at you
every day you have somebody demeaning
you every day you have somebody
destroying your self-confidence every
day you have somebody undermining you
every day you have somebody backstabbing
you every day
um those bosses exist and those jobs
exist but I mean most
I mean if that were the case I mean I
think
I know but boy I mean is that really
true most I had to stigma until I saw
people getting fired without notice
agree agree agree when people work till
midnight no respect agree agree agree I
think there's a lot of comments in here
that I completely agree with all of my
books are basically me railing against
um the way business has gone
for the past 30 years to get it to be
more human Centric I'm simply proposing
that discomfort is part of growth and if
somebody's thinking long term about
their careers that sometimes staying in
a job that's not toxic but a job that
may not be perfect is actually a a great
lesson for growth you know I don't want
to go through that again
but I'm glad it happened you know I mean
I look at jobs that I've had I work for
buses that were pretty crap uh I don't
want that again I don't want to work for
them ever again but I'm glad it happened
because I learned a lot about
camaraderie and I learned a lot about
what not to do
I tell you one thing that does happen
all the time would I rail against the
companies as well which is if you have a
manager that can't hold on to employees
they have huge turnover rates that the
company doesn't seem to think that it's
the manager that's the problem you know
I've seen this happen so many times
they'll go to the manager and say what's
going on they go well it's a difficult
job I can't hold on to people I'm like
hold on the only common factor in all
the people that are churning through
here is you
um so I think companies can do a better
job if they see high churn in a job that
it's probably the leader and I've seen
it happen so many times and usually it's
because that leader is very numbers
driven and they are able to
you know really hurt people to make the
numbers work
um and then people quit
um it's a it's a short-term strategy
that ultimately as we're learning
doesn't pay dividends so I think I agree
with most of the comments that one of
the things I think
that we're doing here is trying to make
a better version of capitalism more
human-centric version of capitalism
well thanks for watching I kind of liked
doing the reaction videos if I'm honest
but if you like it um I'll do more of
them
um yeah thanks for watching